you know we had uh Michael M came on the
show a long time ago and he said that
I'm paraphrasing but the actions of
politicians are letters to Santa without
the police yeah it is the actions of and
and so I've had a lot of people try to
make this play politicians come in here
like oh no no you can't blame the cops
they're good people it's the leadership
that's bad I say I don't care about
leadership Bill DeBlasio can go out in
the middle of the street Buck Naked
scream into the wind for all I care it's
meaningless but if he does it and the
cops then protect him while he's doing
it now that's the problem the individual
officers who are engaging in this
activity this goes back to when DeBlasio
stole taxpayer funds to paint black
lives matter in front of Trump's uh fth
Avenue building and then used I think it
was like 27 police officers to protect
it so stealing from the public coffers
for a political purpose for personal
gain and those cops had Smiles on their
faces while they they did what they were
told that's that's that's that's
policing in New York City